can tell us about the car that was in
the right so there's a car in the short
and if you haven't seen the short go to
manch a film calm and watch it so we
don't you know spoiler alert so yeah you
know we needed this car and need to be a
nice car in the short and it's actually
a zipcar so you know if you go around a
car from a rental house you're going to
show up and they're going to give you a
different car than what you signed up
for you know it's impossible to know the
color of the vehicle you're getting so I
didn't realize that zip car had luxury
vehicles but they do and so the funny
thing was we were actually going to
shoot the exterior seen on day one so I
went and I rented a zipcar and it was
Mercedes and I show up to set on the
first day in a Mercedes and I'm like
great this is a low-budget scrappy short
in the directors like you know we can't
pay you but and I'm pulling up Mercedes
so we didn't get that shot the first day
because you know as I said we're at the
whole gym in a day so we're going to day
two and which was fine because we were
shooting date soon anyway but it just
meant I needed to rent the car again and
so on day two I get a call from zipcar
and for those who don't have a zipcar in
their cities of cars a place where you
can rent a vehicle by the hour as
opposed to buy the day and you remember
in the gas and insurance is included the
thing I was worried about was there
gonna be a big zip car sticker on the
back and that would kind of ruin it but
thankfully their luxury vehicles at
least right now don't have branding on
it so day two I got a call from zipcar
saying we're sorry sir but the zipcar
you have preserved was just in an
accident and is no longer available so
it's classic Murphy's Law indie-film
stuff like you try and imagine
everything then go wrong but I didn't
imagine that money on my car smashed up
by the side of the road right now the
one that I had reserved so I said to
them well this was a strange request but
I need you to find me that same vehicle
for all day you know or at least a
vehicle close like close to it and you
know I rented the silver ones that would
show up at night in the
I it's better as opposed to a black or
dark blue or something so you know even
even just having the vehicle wasn't chat
was a challenge but then of course on
day two here i am showing up on set in a
different luxury vehicle than i did in a
day once I show up in a Mercedes on day
one and then I'm day two I show up in
the BMW and it's like yeah you know
indie film that's that's that's how we
do things over here we don't spend the
money on the personnel we spend it all
on our transport to the set apparently
you